is
my
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hmm yeah there's a slurp
that was there it is yes my mic is
sounding really loud right now that's
good
too but i know so many of you yesterday
said that uh you enjoyed that sound of
the uh the slurp
they're weird people i wish my wife felt
the same about my sleep apnea
since i've hurt my knee i have gained
weight but look i got these bumps
growing all over oh my gosh i've been
doing the curls at the gym since i can't
do the squats so might as well
i'm gonna have a little trouble with
that closet door gerald is here
how are you sir well how are you quarter
black garrett is here
dave landau is here you can find him at
compound media and somewhere in omaha
uh i'll be in omaha and uh raleigh and
detroit when when in omaha i will be in
omaha in the beginning of march
beginning of march
yes what is that crowd like they're good
you know what i'm saying it doesn't have
to be spaced out
salt of the earth yeah does have to uh
six do they salt the crowd
before they go i believe it's a six it's
six feet between each table oh well
that's great for comedy compression
it is what you want to do is create a
roll so if there's any way to avoid that
right yes exactly it's like the wave
just starts and someone
no he's over there it's just one guy
starts the wave and everybody's like no
sir no sir
no you are a disappointment and i could
hurt you we have
mike rowe on the show we have a lot
there's so much new news
yesterday we had to get our sea legs a
little bit because we are suing facebook
and uh you can go read about that case
at loud with credit.com let me say this
to you really quickly um lot of
credit.com
club credit returns you get 30 off how
can you support the lawsuit
just join mug club or go to the merch
shop that's it if you want to pay full
price instead of the discount
we don't really do the charity thing
here that's why we haven't done patreon
we want to have a self-sustaining
business
where we can we can be the people who
you know in uh offices at zuckerberg
they go [ __ ]
right exactly again you can show your
support for us online right on social
media and letting people know what we're
doing
that's a great way to support uh we'll
also be talking about anal swabs which
is new with the cove double masking from
fauci
as well as aoc beautiful and brave uh
survivor story that's right
newly survived um
dave landa looks very concerned that's
why i didn't want to put the map on
there because now you're staring at it
like
it's black history month
yeah oh little known fact so every week
we're gonna be dropping you
every day some uh black history month
facts that you may not know you all know
about the rosa parks and the railroad
harriet tubman uh before the fbi
murdered him uh martin luther king jr
dropped a mixtape under his rap alter
ego little dreamer good morning really
yeah so um anything to add there
i just uh yeah mlk kkk is most wanted
that was oh
wow that's not good no that's an ice
cube
guy's ice cube i don't know what he's
talking about send your letters at dave
landis but you know what
i show up in omaha with a hefty jacket
so we don't know what's under it yeah
it's just all the black people in omaha
it's hot in here yeah they're all
showing up i would say it's hot in here
but i'm also wearing
level three yeah that's spartan armor
it's a yeah it's uh
we'll talk about him a little bit later
no insurrection in this studio but first
this is the story that is breaking right
now it's making the rounds on all the
twitter
um and we always have to be careful
because um you can never
joke about this and you can never
question any facts even in the absence
of
any um but aoc did a 90-minute stream on
instagram
live yesterday and uh um
there are a lot of claims in there let's
start with um let's just
let's let's let it straight from the hor
the horse-faced mouth
like i'm here and the bathroom door
starts going like this
like the bathroom door is behind me or
rather in front of me and i'm like this
and the door hinges right here and i
just hear
she's got a future off broadway where is
she i mean i thought i was going to die
is because these folks who tell us to
move on
that it's not a big deal that we should
forget what's happened
or even telling us to apologize
no one said that these are the same
tactics of abusers
it just turned out whereas she was the
doordash guy
with her chimichangas and i haven't told
many people that in my life
whether you experience any sort of
trauma
um in your life small to large
these episodes can compound on one
another
there's no you know something really big
happening to you
and then you
deal with it and then you move on and
then when something else happens
to you you deal with that okay so look i
don't want to say because we don't know
right um and you know some people say
believe all women as they believe all
facts
and i think that if this happened listen
aoc horrible if you were sexually
assaulted
these men should be buried beneath the
railroad tracks okay does everyone else
here agree
now why might i think it's a little
bullshitty is
okay go with me here uh because you
equivocated
but you created equivalency between
sexual assault
and verbal abuse you created an
equivalency between the crips running a
train on somebody locked in the closet
for days on end and the insults from
gazoo
hmm not the same
i need to go to my counselor yeah i just
don't like when people say
almost died when they didn't almost die
yeah
how can you prove what she's saying yes
people storming the capital if they're
saying kill all the senators is a bad
thing and you would want to run away
from that and it would be kind of a
scarring experience
for us to endure right i would
absolutely give you that but nobody can
back up her story of what she's saying
like
if that happened then that's horrible
that is terrible but
did it really happen i don't believe her
very insensitive that the
the insurrectionists weren't asking
where is z
oh that's true boy this is a dead room
thanks i just don't know how i'm
supposed to play this one
i got to be here dave don't make any
rape jokes because they'll
of course listen we're not and rape is
bad
[Laughter]
and it reminded me of the time that i
was teased yeah it was
i almost died because yeah well nothing
happened really nothing really happened
well yeah once she said that ted cruz
tried to murder her i think that's when
i stopped believing her even more
which by the way senator ted cruz you're
welcome to be on the show but it's not a
softball you've got some splaining
through though
not a big fan crews you guys could talk
beards
cruise missile turned into more of a dud
yeah what was that i was trying is that
your wedding no
no and here she is now she moves forward
aoc
talking about you can you follow the
puck when landau's laughing at my ribs
on gerald
okay do it do it do it gerald deserves
everything he gets
aoc now here she is talking about uh
speaking of cruz uh
recent disappointment but i don't know
hey you know what senator cruz some
people are saying that you don't believe
there was
any election irregularities um i don't i
want you to
defend your position in your own words
but it does need to be defended
just my opinion this is this is i should
have worn the undercover
yeah vest here's the oc talking about
holly and cruz
is that when given another window of
political opportunity for themselves
even if they know that it means
that it will endanger their colleagues
they will do it again and that's the
real reason why i think
that senator josh hawley needs to resign
why senator ted cruz needs to resign
along with many others because they will
do it again
it will do what again exactly the tall
glass of unity
this is like look we need to unify okay
we understand
those nazis tried to kill me how does
this work
do you notice this happened with barack
obama too they were they were referring
to george w bush as a nazi yeah right
you couldn't actually say you know what
actually i don't think george w bush is
as bad as
halliburton that was for about eight
frickin
years yeah and then when barack obama
came in they said it's time for unity
it's time for unity where the very first
executive action was reversing the
mexico city policy
where our taxpayer dollars went to fund
abortions overseas
donald trump reversed that and then joe
biden because priorities made sure that
your tax dollars are funding abortion
overseas again
unity unity you need to resign we need
to impeach we need to kick them out
and ted cruz tried to kill me oh i don't
know i mean maybe we should unify
in telling you to go fornicate yourself
in the wire brush i think we can do what
what is the worst thing that ted cruz
said throughout this entire thing i mean
i'm really searching for the thing that
she's saying
that's what he said that made people
want to murder me because he said
let's have a concert let's have an
inquiry uh over the next 10 days i think
on on the sixth and that's what he
wanted to do he was going to represent
the states that filed the lawsuit in the
supreme court that never actually got to
the supreme
court other than that he said there were
irregularities and things we needed to
look into
if the if you're lowering the bar fine
let's slow it for everybody
every one of you who said something
about black lives matter and said it's
fine to be
out outraged and said that you're more
likely as a black person be shot by a
cop than a white person which is a lie
by the way that incited people to
violence by the way
let's paul you before aoc is a petulant
child who was carried by
satan in the desert and passion of the
christ she was a little baby
on the shoulder really do you think she
acts like a toddler i think
i don't think so i don't think she's
evil i think look no
i think and we'll be doing a roast of
greta thunderberg tomorrow that's one of
the best things that's happening
yeah she's 18 now so we're not in
violation of
youtube's guidelines criticizing someone
who
serves to actually pressure legislative
policy
and she was replaced immediately when
she turned 18. she was replaced
immediately
like michael jackson seeing a pubic hand
right out
and david hogg wondering where all the
people who said he was cute went to oh
sorry david oh and we're gonna be
talking about impeachment look uh do you
think this is i guess this is my
question here do you think that there's
any constitutionality for impeachment
right now
and uh what do you think people believe
at this point i feel like we are living
in a world
where it's a lie that is agreed upon it
we're talking about covet and double
mask and we'll get to that in a second
actually can we show that really quickly
i think we're going to tease this really
quick
because coming up it's been a flip-flop
but remember when doctor
no strings to hold him down fouchy said
this about double masking
so if you have a physical covering with
one layer you put another layer on it
just makes common sense
that it likely would be more effective
turns out that's all [ __ ]
oh by the way i think we're breaking we
do actually have um
some updates we have uh uh a mugshot of
the attacker from aoc if i see written
yeah well listen the means of
reproduction yeah
terrible
she's disgusting terrible joe louis you
deserve better
uh we're going to be talking about that
this is a part of the lie that is agreed
upon
listen if if you actually believed that
this pandemic was as deadly as they
tried to claim it was or like ebola
where in liberia had a 15
survival rate and only two organizations
went in one of whom was samaritan's
purse
do you think two layers of your neck
gator would make you feel any safer
the issue with nancy pelosi the issue
with gavin newsom going out to dinners
and the issue with nancy pelosi getting
a blowout in a particle vortex right and
they get caught again and again and
again is not hypocrisy
right listen everyone here is a
hypocrite i'm faithful to my wife
sometimes there's a nice big pair of
tits and i go
and don't look because i'm a hypocrite
i'm a man i'm attracted to press
i wouldn't listen come on don't sell
yourself short you have tremendous tits
thank you thank you they are real and
they are spectacular
we're all hypocrites it's that they
aren't actually
afraid these people aren't actually
afraid of the virus
with a 50 mortality rate or even a 7
mortality rate
the idea of the election being just like
every other election before us that
joe biden who never campaigned who never
left his basement received more votes
than any president throughout
the entirety of american history and
that there's this widespread coalition
and nothing untoward happened this is a
lie
that is agreed upon the idea that
there's science and you double mask and
you triple mask and we should trust the
world health organization
it's a lie that's agreed upon the idea
that there's any legitimacy to
impeaching a
former president or president this is a
lie
that is agreed upon and any republicans
who go along with that lie
well um your wieners so i think that if
you do want two pla
two masks though just put a plastic bag
over your face
and let the lord call you home yes put a
plastic bag over your face with an extra
filter of packing peanuts
yes i'd say three masks
why not four yeah yeah exactly okay
uh by the way if you uh want to support
we're gonna might grow up in a little
bit but uh subscribe on apple podcast
and android for the audio only version
uh you can go there when you're on the
road i don't know why you listen to
audio only
and the best thing you can do is just
hit like
on this show whether you're watching
live or afterward just hit like it helps
the algorithms and comment comment
comment just leave a comment i know you
can't comment live
we don't do live chat on youtube because
we don't want to be held liable for all
the horrible things that you say
we love you but some of you a little bit
crazy a little bit lonely and we get
that this is a purge for you we want
nothing to do with that but once the
show is archived
just leave a comment and you know what
today uh you can answer the question of
the
day
tell me your favorite dog what's your
favorite doll it could be a name
or a breed if you like cats kill
yourself um we'll be taking your mug
club chat a little bit later on
with my bro yeah i'm not really a big
fan no no
not only garfield but the weird people
who have all the snoopy gear you know
those people like here
my mom is both really man oh wow yeah
tweety birds on the spectrum
his mom's got a little bit of greta
thundering oh come on do you think
that's really
she's texting me right now you deal with
somebody you're like listen i don't know
how you are with asperger's but what do
you think of snoopy
and you're like why let me know how much
stuff oh i love snoopy my
favorite yeah let's say take notes set
three garfield things
clinged to the back of your car in the
back window
all right gerald has some strong
opinions on this and let me know
whatever's happening on cnn because i
know it's a slow news day when people
are spending all of this time about
claims with
no substantiation whatsoever sexual
assault did she claim that the sexual
assault happened in
the capitol no i don't think that's what
she was saying well i'll assume she did
um so what's happening right now and
this is the lie that is agreed upon by
the media they want you to believe that
this is common practice that this has
happened
uh at some point any point throughout
american history it hasn't
uh that president donald trump uh in
contrast to former vice president joe
biden
uh could be impeached even though he's
out of office this is their new plan
he's open and mueller is pretty
expressed on this in his report he says
uh that trump can be indicted after he
leaves office and in the interim
there's a possibility of congressional
impeachment an official
can be impeached even after
uh they leave office if you say it
enough
chapter from our history tells us that
trump can be impeached and can be tried
in the senate
even after he leaves office by the way
if you don't uh cut that man out
properly before serving him he can
poison you
what hoverfish is that a handsome
contest
[Laughter]
you all get party favors beautiful
people but no one gets first
um okay let me read this to you really
quickly so article two
section four it's pretty clear
impeachment is for removal from
office the president shall be removed
from office on impeachment for
and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes
and misdemeanors and the founders right
they base the requirements for
impeachment on this this is something a
lot of people don't know i have to get a
little nerdy on the english practice
um except they altered it of course to
specifically more apply to public
officials because we don't really have
royalty
uh unlike you canadians my home country
where you still keep the queen on your
monkey
your money your [ __ ] your [ __ ] all
of you canada listen here's a good
here's a good rule of thumb
if you are a neighbor right to the north
of a country that fought off the royalty
and the most powerful
economic superpower of one century only
to become
the next great economic superpower of uh
the following century and you still
keep the royalty on your money
listen when african colonies that have
no weapons can revolt get the crown out
of their country
yeah when the french get their own
province is it looney royal
i am i have no i i don't know what the i
don't even know what it means honestly
i know what it is the toonie it looks
like a peso
it's a silly country the fact that it
isn't a 51st
state right is proof that we are not an
evil employer i know yeah it's also
funny because strippers are like thank
you for the change
because it's it's your rite of passage
when you're i'm from detroit you go over
there you're 19. you can drink
right yes you know so you go over there
and you give you give silly goose money
to them never has a more
some more accurate summary of canada
been described so
uh the founders right they they they
switched it to apply to public officials
let me read you
uh here from the founding documents the
constitution established an impeachment
mechanism exclusively geared toward
holding public officials including
the president accountable this
contrasted with english practice of
impeachment which would extend to any
individual
save the crown not the crappy series i
haven't actually watched the series
that's bad come on and uh there's here's
the thing too people will say well you
know what okay maybe you're just talking
about the law on the history
precedent also matters you can see how
this has applied
in practice uh congress the annotated
right the constitution states the
framers
they were very clearly envisioned
punishment okay for impeachment
exclusively
exclusively for removal from office
that's what it means
that's what it's for it's censure is a
different thing
right which for me for a long time like
they're they can censor no censure
is basically public admonishment it's
basically the modern day stocks
only there are no consequences it's like
a slap on the wrist basically for a
public official
the american colonies largely limited
impeachment to office holders on the
basis of misconduct committed in
office and the available punishment for
impeachment was limited to removal
from office again while we're talking
about precedent nixon
resigned why he resigned so that he
wouldn't be impeached
and they didn't impeach him after and
they really wanted to impeach him and
ford was another
[ __ ] he pardoned him later on although
gerald ford he smoked
six bowls of pipe tobacco a day and he
died at 94.
he was totally healthy good man good he
was a good man gerald ford
you know didn't do a whole lot you know
what no one has said in the last 10
years
he hates gerald fort no he just kind of
went away
right through have you ever been to the
gerald ford library in grand rapids i
assure you i haven't
it's basically a pizza slice is it it's
like so
it's like a pizza slice and it starts
off with you know memorabilia from
gerald ford you know the two years
and uh then as you go back there's an
elvis exhibit
you're like we need to fill in some
spaces just like go to the gerald ford
museum there's nothing left like yeah
elvis and there's chuck berry like what
about gerald ford wow he played here at
grand rapids high
that was at the front yeah and uh you
know also we have an ikea display here
because there's kind of a partnership
is the chuck berry display just in the
women's room
[Laughter]
right where aoc is hiding yes apparently
so well so there one bit of information
i wanted to
try to kill me with his kick i went in
one room where i knew men couldn't
no there's no safe place now men can go
in the women's restroom so allowed
everybody to
beat the hell out of women at sports
well i wouldn't yeah progress
did you see that that dude he looked
like keith david in a wig
okay okay you had some points yeah so on
the constitutionality of it right i
think you've made a very good point that
obviously the only punishment is removal
from office the only thing that goes
with that is the inability to run for
future office
right and i think that's really what
they're getting at is they're trying to
bend the rules
and continue an impeachment process
meant to remove somebody from office so
that they can go hahaha
2024 you're out and i don't think like
are you really that afraid of donald
trump
they absolutely are he's going to be the
guy they absolutely are they check their
beds for donald trump i really do think
they are afraid of him but
that goes to another level but you can't
thinking that you can impeach
a former politician somebody who doesn't
hold office anymore and that it will
have any effect whatsoever because
they're looking at this and saying
impeach indict
imprison so this isn't just one thing
that they're trying to do and yes
after a president is removed from office
he goes back to being a private citizen
who can be held liable in a court of law
but guess what
it would have to go through the courts
unless you're a biden
unless you're snorting coke off your
niece's hip bones you could be pardoned
on the roadblock yeah no they absolutely
are afraid of trump aoc checks her
clothes trump are you in there
again you try to hurt me no it's just
but i died getting pants
trump's like listen aoc i only
hurt i only go for russian models you're
fine
it could be no no no no no no no
the abercrombie ethnic kind of
mysterious a little exotic it doesn't
really get you quite across the finish
line
because you're toothy so oh there she is
right now look cnn talking about aoc
and i haven't told many people i haven't
told many people except
all my social media and cnn and my
publicist to send out a press release
so the first person i'm going to tell is
everybody and my turtleneck guy
yes on each other
she's just on a pair of tweets following
that the congresswoman
wrote this quote my story isn't the only
story
it's just one story of many of those
whose lives were endangered at the
capitol by the lies the threats and the
violence fanned by the cowardice of
people
who chose personal gain above oh
come on we're going to remember when
glasses would make people look smarter
[Laughter]
the cowardice you worked as a barmaid
and then suckled at the taxpayer teat
because you won a race from an incumbent
who didn't show up for a debate
you've never taken a risk you can say
what you want about donald trump
the guy risked a whole lot for a salary
that was four hundred thousand dollars
it hasn't even really been adjusted for
inflation
he could find four hundred thousand
dollars in his suit jacket pocket that
he accidentally drapes over a hobo
on the way to trump tower and not
discern that lack of finance in his
account
we talk about cowardice listen i
understand why people are upset with
conspiracy theorists and i
i don't i don't like seeing people in
nancy pelosi's that is the people's
house yeah i don't think that's the
process
i think that a lot of people had they
felt their voices weren't heard and i
understand why your voices weren't heard
because
people didn't do the work that they
needed to do when i say you were played
by people at the top as it relates to
election irregularities and fraud people
weren't doing their due diligence okay
you can see it by the typos and the
briefs you can see by the fact that
behind the scenes we had to correct some
of this data and it's really hard for
us when we have the truth we've tried to
talk about the truth in the show we go
look
x thousand voter rolls here these are
addresses that don't exist that's what
we were going to do in nevada you know
what comment below let us know if you
still want us to do
the nevada live stream where we just
show you 40 addresses with random places
that don't exist
maybe it's more relevant now because
they're banning anyone who shows you the
truth we can still do it my heart gave
out i apologize
it was too small but the point is they
weren't doing their due diligence and so
people were waiting for those who had
the ability
to do something to affect change and
they didn't and that's
and when those same people are being
labeled nazis
and being labeled enemies of the state
then they say well you know what all
right i guess i guess i'm an enemy of
the state now
and now they call for unity and they
want to call for unity
by tarring and feathering the man who
actually support when i say
i don't mean conspiracy theorists i
don't mean radical right-wingers i mean
the man
who actually fought for small businesses
the man who unions are finding out the
hard way now
actually fought for the american working
class the man who was
loathed by hedge funders right you
decide that you want to vilify
this man while you simultaneously
protect all of your cronies in wall
street and big tech and big media and
you wonder why people
are upset all right
hit the notification bell by the way if
you're subscribed because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot as we talk about
big tech and we are
suing facebook yes go read the story
it's not the same as like this is a big
one
how real with the insurgents though how
i mean were they
actually republicans i don't that's the
part that i'm really curious of people
it seems like it was a mix
yeah yeah at the very least and there
were some crazy people who actually
believed that joe biden was going to be
arrested on january 20th
this is what i will say the people the
people out there who thought it was all
part of the plan
and i've never been a conspiracy
theorist they try to act in the realm of
facts and it doesn't mean that there
aren't some conspiracies that are true
do i think that clinton's killed people
yeah come on but
some people are telling me this is their
thing this is actually all part of the
plan with donald trump
the whole part of the plan to expose
voter fraud he's going to do this and
then in the
end of four years exposed voter from
like okay i don't think that's part of
the plan then they go it's all part of
the plan
january 6th and then people are saying
it's all part of the plan january 20th
joe biden's going to be arrested look
look look if you believe that you're
stupid
anyone let me tell you you've never run
a business you've never been in combat
you have never had to lead people
you do not set a plan in motion which
allows
for zero contingencies it would be like
jacob's saying all right okay listen
we're going into kandahar okay we're
going to let them surround us wait john
go that's another
go with me here how many how many people
do we have we only have uh we have 11
troops okay we're going to let them kill
uh 10 first no no wait don't go hey i've
got them right where i want them
then i'm going to put up the white flag
and then then the cavalry will come over
the hill you don't make that plan
so don't let yourself be led astray just
like a stupid branding play named
robin hood you idiot bernie bros
well i guess you've never lost a game of
11d chess
[Music]
but every time it failed they were like
well now it's going to be 6d chess
i don't think it it stopped at 3. i will
tell you there was a lot of disorganized
and i can't
i can't always reveal names we've always
tried to welcome but there was a lot of
disorganization at the top
that was disheartening it was
disheartening because we were doing this
work behind the scenes and
listen but it doesn't mean that these
people are people didn't feel their
voice was hurt and that is true
because democrats were trying to
completely shut down giant
swaths of evidence which were never
heard that being said
the people whose responsibility it was
to make
sure that the cases were airtight didn't
do
their job my disappointment is not with
these things being thrown out my
disappointment is not just it's with
the irresponsibility in not doing your
due diligence because
this was something that could have been
a watershed moment and instead yeah you
screwed the pooch
well and i'm not talking about you joe
lewis don't take it personally you
wouldn't screw him
you're adorable um i think one of the
things that frustrates me
i wouldn't screw him that's disgusting
what you would screw him no i'm saying
what is right see look
this is what happens when you don't have
a comedian he thinks like bestiality
this is why washington carver invented
peanut butter
dogs
look at his face he's the face of a 14
year old he's never had a wrinkle go
make your point there gerald
i'm gonna say that that's the biggest
thing in this that i want to make sure
happens is that at some point
that the flames cool down enough to
where you can actually take a
non-partisan look
back at what happened during this
election and go okay we need to fix
things but it will never happen
and i don't think it will at least
because guys like jake tap are out there
saying it's the big lie
right which was what was used to
describe what the nazis did
right and so anybody who thinks there
was any shred
of craziness oh wait hold on hold that
thought look chicago teachers unions
demands okay hold on reopening this is
on cnn reopening metric based cdc guys
not a single demand was for the
bettering of teaching
or did you notice that yeah none of it
had anything to do with the children
yeah but unions are for the children
yeah okay
i had a very 50s haircut yeah i know
yeah so anyway
this is the guy who wouldn't be allowed
in the office in mad men
can i come in not by the hair of our
chinny chin well no that's a great
example though stephen it's every single
issue that we have it you're again if
you're
against public schools because they are
terrible places where people go and
don't get educated you hate teachers
teachers who are sacrificing and and
then they'll trot out the story of them
right they'll buy the supplies and i'm
sacrificing for the kids and then stuff
like this happens and it's clear they're
not for the kids and then aoc goes on
here and that's the problem that i have
with this
not that if she was a victim of sexual
assault or had a terrible experience in
the capital that we shouldn't be
i guess compassionate for that obviously
right and try to fix it but that she's
using it so obviously to push something
that's a lie
the idiots of the capitol hold on to
being murdered with ted cruz i know
that's what i'm saying like that's
nothing to do with the fact
that there were voter roles that didn't
balance that didn't match up yeah and
that there were thousands of people who
voted for addresses
that wouldn't exist yeah right was
extending an olive branch to get her to
agree
and then she responded with that
ridiculous murder
she's like she's like lenny with the
rabbit only it was a peace dove offering
i didn't know i wasn't i wanted veins on
my ketchup
right that's too close to reality he
doesn't like ted cruz
like richard
too far just give them a chance empty
toilet paper roll filled with dryer
sheets leave them alone
um but isn't it strange like of all the
things that trump said
i really feel that this is a case where
he didn't say
anything wrong at all remember he went
out of his way so this is a good example
he went
out of his way to try and be peaceful so
sorry we're circling back to the
impeachment i didn't mean to bring a
circle back
no no we should we need to finish this
we need to talk about the impeachment
yeah they are claiming i think we
we have clip c where this is them
claiming that he incited violence
at the capitol or is this the trump clip
clippy is uh clippy
is them claiming so their claim and the
aoc claim and they try to extend it to
uh ted cruz and holly writing all of
these people is that
donald trump was inciting violence and
that's the reason
that he should be impeached
post-presidency which
of course doesn't happen hasn't happened
and will not happen and they were
writing up
these articles of impeachment i want to
read a portion of it to you here it says
donald john trump engaged in high crimes
and misdemeanors
by willfully inciting violence against
the government of the united states
they were provoked by the president
rachel levine the president bears
responsibility for wednesday's attack on
congress by mob rioters
and we know that the president of the
united states incited this insurrection
cosplaying as a scorpion if they believe
donald john
donald john trump cited the erection
ah there it is you bet he did
too much spirit cooking going on behind
the scenes um okay so let's look at this
timeline and actually i want you to give
me the uh
uh token allen here we can find or uh
lily i forgot to include this
the record for um the mile running the
mile how
quick it is because uh here is at 12
16 p.m here's a timeline 12 16 p.m
eastern standard time
or as i call it the devil's time uh this
is the speech from donald trump where he
called for violence you can hear from
his mouth
i know that everyone here will soon be
marching over to the capitol building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard
oh wow showmap was incorrect i apologize
i take it back
that is clearly i need to do my due
diligence
yes those who hand me shekels told me to
say
that he encouraged violence i'm a tall
jew haven't you seen the anti-semitic
comments
i have yeah yeah that's the end
which is weird that was that was at 12
16. then it was
at 1 10 they began grappling
with the police right we have an overlay
here 1 10 p.m they began grappling with
the police
a minute later that this is uh bring up
this overlay here at 1
11 p.m uh the white house speech
ended okay okay the capital was 1.8
miles away from the speech
at the white house how long did it take
for them to actually get there when they
actually started getting into the
building
do we have i don't i thought we had this
on the map get this token out and get it
to move
it's faster than this it's faster than a
minute it's faster than the
miles yeah and it's 1.8 miles they did
it faster than the fastest people in the
history of mankind could have done it
because they were really inspired by
donald trump saying make your voices
peacefully hurt
and patriotically yeah and they were uh
they were heavy some of them yeah some
of us
some of them some of them were heavy i
don't wanna i don't wanna insult anyone
but well they're down it could be a
little stocky
you know a little girl okay corelli and
you know it's not it's what's not heavy
is my spartan armor and spartan armor
systems we'll talk about a little bit
later this is unbelievably light it's
comfortable it's light i can breathe
even with my bad heart
it's not compressing it further and this
is another claim that they're making
they're making the claim that trump
could be convicted uh in the senate
impeachment trial
here's the thing 45 senate republicans
they already voted
with rand paul who i i really do like
rand paul he's one of the few guys
just stop being so catty
i love he doesn't need to be so [ __ ]
no he's he's like a gay man watching sex
in the city
well really if sarah only understood the
constitutionality of the operation
you know you know what i actually i look
i like this bill ran but i just want to
kick the [ __ ] out of you
right i don't know why so you know
they're not going to do anything with it
right i mean
there's no way no no no so uh that means
they could never reach the two-thirds no
of the majority required
they could absolutely never reach the
two-thirds of the majority required to
impeach donald trump yeah and you know
why we put in two-thirds
when you read back through some of the
historical context they put in
two-thirds so it would not be a purely
partisan
issue right right which we don't have in
that which should be the part that
should be
irrelevant in the era of unity gerald
yes
we should all be throwing around words
like partisan that get us auto throttled
on youtube
please so we should be unified in
breaking the law
i just bought an auto throttler i just
i just shorted the stock of an auto
throttler oh good
yeah just because i'm hoping one of
these days i'm just gonna when i walk
off from this i'm just gonna short the
stock of some stuff i'll just be like
sell your position
i do it sell your position on 7-eleven
and racetrack
and buy quick trip if it were publicly
traded family video can see you doing
that actually
hey get rid of blockbuster dude do you
have any opinions here dave is more of a
political
cause look a good example dave landau is
a guy who i know wasn't really political
he's not a
republican not necessarily conservative
but you've sort of developed here over
the last few years because you've seen
this this tight grip this death grip
that they try to have on really have you
made this point yesterday the pursuit of
happiness they're trying to take that
away for the first time in american
history the first time yeah it is the
first time in american history that
people are not able to open up their
stores
they are being punished for just being
alive they're locked inside
like you just start seeing people being
attacked every single day people going
crazy
it it's sad and it's the first time that
we've ever experienced this in this
country like that's my
serious opinion and somebody who i would
say identified like more of like a
george carlin liberal where i just hate
everything
right i wouldn't really call it liberal
but i'm definitely i
i move a little right now obviously
because none of
like that's not the left this is just a
group of people
who want to take down america and that's
what bob i don't even think you moved to
the right a little bit
like where david like dave rubin is like
well it's a classical liberal because
you know where you line up on issues
these lockdowns are absurd locking out
individual investors is absurd locking
down freedom of speech is absurd
increasing taxes on middle-class
businesses is absurd that makes you
talk about a wide tent the fact that
dave landau would be considered
an enemy of the state by someone like an
aoc absolutely
you would consider yourself moderate
they consider you radical right exactly
because they are the radical left that's
there really is only a radical left
let me ask who is the moderate left
right now yeah right now who is the
moderate left joe biden was sold as the
most
moderate that and true he doesn't know
what he's saying
that's also why i think they're going to
weaken it bernie's this guy until the
end of the term it doesn't matter what
happens
because if we just sign what's in front
of you well i think we should
sure no it's like a rest another
executive order button mm-hmm
with a head injury doing autographs
they're just like just keep going he's
like yeah
well dave i think one of the reasons
that you have moved to the right as you
say
the president who needs a leather helmet
or wore one at one time
really caused some issues that's part of
the problem air pockets
you you had a case study in in your
hometown
on what would happen if liberals got
their way right yeah you saw what
happened when liberals got their way
people moved out animals moved in drug
dealers moved in and uh
all kinds of craziness happened right so
you had something right in front of you
to say i've not heard of that in detroit
but
uh you know i'll take your word
every year every year they'll be like a
panda or something escaping from a drug
dealer's house
and just walking around they're like if
you see a tiger out there with a pierced
ear
that belongs to a guy named tron yeah
and also a rival gang is trying to take
it out but that's
primarily because he pierced the gay ear
exactly the wrong
side we're not big on that in detroit
it's not good
exotic just they're protected
that's a name i haven't heard in a while
okay so nothing more look
impeachment is political here's the
here's the main takeaway for impeachment
for people who are out there listening
look
um it's silly this is theatrics
okay and this is designed to fragment
the country while they try to call
everyone together for uni they are not
interested in unity impeaching
a former president right of course at
the behest of the current former vice
president impeaching a former president
is unprecedented it's unconstitutional
they have no interest
in unifying with anyone provide i don't
want to say anyone but
if you have some limitations for example
on abortions where you don't believe
that babies should be killed up until
and including birth
they don't want to unify with you if you
believe that you should have the right
to protect your life and limb and family
with your own firearms and your god
god ordained a constitutionally
protected second amendment right
they don't want to unify with you if you
believe that you should be able to
express unpopular opinions on social
media or out in a
town square they don't want to unify
with you if you believe that
middle-income families actually deserve
the right to go to work and businesses
deserve the right to hire people and
open responsibly
they don't want to unify with you if you
believe that individual investors should
be able to invest their own money in the
exact same
kind of parlor tricks that wall street
do they don't want to unify with you
they only want to unify
with you if you run one of these big
tech companies if you run one of these
big wall street
firms or if you are one of the very
small percentage of republicans who want
to virtue
signal to democrats as a part of the
sham impeachment because they're
starting their next lincoln project
where they are undoubtedly
molesting children in closets those are
the only people they want to unify with
and guess what i'm not putting on that
teen
jersey but um i do put on the team
jersey of
spartan armor we're going to talk about
double masking what
oh what the dave i'm so sorry
i was just playing with it that is a
gross
violation of firearm safety i thought
you like guns here
i do i don't want to be shot with them
no oh i it works
point that over there no you're not
we'll stop
put it down look at it put it down and
aim it away from the trigger
yeah i'm not aiming at the dog no put it
put it on the couch there you go
on this couch yeah that couch that's
fine should i throw it just throw it
yeah which by the trigger yeah just
throw it as i get to my uh plug
my wonderful sponsor who will
undoubtedly be happy spartan armor by
the way
they have the balls to sponsor this show
and listen you don't have to be some
crazy conspiracy theorist to actually
want to be able to protect yourself from
some kind of an active shooter situation
this is really like or dave this is
something that i wear it's a plate
carrier
um but they have something that go under
your clothes that are really light
they're absolutely
44 magnum proof and stab uh some of them
are stabbed proof some of them are stab
resistant
something that's really big with spartan
armor there are a lot of armor carriers
out there
and they say that they're nij equivalent
is that something
these ones are actually nij certified
yeah by
they're actually certified which is a
real thing it's a certification it's
like
a pharmaceutical versus a supplement
that says like well you know we promise
that what's on the labels on the label
how do i know
ah you screwed up you trusted us so
their stuff is nij certified um you can
go to smartnumbersystems.com
and use the promo code crowder you get
10 percent off
all the time spartan armor and sometimes
you can't even tell when we're wearing
them yeah the thing that i had on
election night that thing was light
the only thing is i don't want you to
shoot me too much because then it does
you know it compromises it
i know i it wasn't on purpose well next
time it'll be you i will say allah
akhabara next time
yeah you have to use a knife give us a
heads up so a knife is good yeah
all right a guy with a walmart and uh so
is it stab resistant just depending on
if it's aoc stabbing you then it's
actually
stab proof stab resistant if it's if
you're in if you're a mitz antifa you
can consider it stab proof
yeah that's strong
if the proud boys show up you might want
to add some uh some tin foil yeah
they're using their parents garbage
cans and shields mom i'm fighting
fascists
stop cutting holes in the recycling bin
by being a fascist yeah exactly it's
basically a group of uh
of the sun from shit's creek so let's go
this is another thing a lie that's
agreed upon
do you remember this this is something
remember uh the the the double masking
and here's the thing it's really
important we're gonna get to all of
fouchy's flip-flops maybe tomorrow maybe
on another day because i think it's
important for people to be held
accountable
and of course those in the scientific
community really those who politicize
science at the top are never held
accountable
but many of you may not remember this so
let's give you a timeline this wasn't
that long ago
doctor who hasn't seen a patient in
several decades still a doctor
fauci uh said that wearing two masks
was something you should do so if you
have a physical covering with one layer
you put another layer on it just makes
common sense
okay now don't you love how when people
were talking about like
hydroxychloroquine or these other they
go
look if this is treating some kind of an
immune response and it you know
some sort of uh an inflamed immune
response some of the other
immunomodulators or anti-inflammatories
it makes sense that they might work
through the same mechanism of action
well there's no
science for that but now you're saying
when someone puts on
a smiley face don't worry be happy
double target mask
oh you know what listen that's good
enough for me that's a double blind
golden standard trial well
this was taken so seriously that
everyone
in the current administration including
our former voice former vice president
wore double masks here you go look at
this
look at all these people where are you
token island bring up the overlay bring
up the overlay token
we need to see all these people being
stupid there you go look at that
you got kamala harris you got chucky you
got butt gig
you got fouchy himself butt gig again
and biden
biden actually didn't realize he had
already had a mask on what's funny is
biden did it over an n95 mask just
because he wanted to virtue like no one
is saying you need a second mask
over an n95 mask he's like screw him
i'll show him that i really care
this is better i think it was a total
accident then he was like you better
tell them that they need this
that's where the box please biden it's
embarrassing listen come on i'm hanging
on by a very thin thread here man
barely here i love how he said it's
common
it's common sense well common sense
apparently does not the scientific
process make because it turns out
there's no science to it here he is now
many people who feel you know if you
really want to have an extra
little uh bit of protection maybe i
should put
two masks on there's nothing wrong with
that but there's no
data that indicates that that is going
to make a difference and that's the
reason why
the cdc has not changed the
recommendation you dismissive prick
this guy's like yeah he's like maybe
some people think wearing
two masks they take it because of you
that was you they think it because of
you
it would have come from nobody else if
not your little geppetto pinocchio ass
okay this guy is afraid
simon says with america yeah
and listen it's not my fault i'm not
very good at simon says i prefer
bop it pop it twist it bang it spin it
it's crazy you know what he just did
though he said there's nothing
brothers he said shut up there's nothing
wrong with that he said there's nothing
wrong with too many guess what
there is there's a lot wrong with me you
know why if you play
listen if you put two masks on you can't
get enough air flow through the mask and
so it comes in and out from the sides
there are several products here's the
thing there are several problems with
two masks
one it may make the mask fit improperly
or the second mask fit improperly you're
more likely to be fiddling with it
with your hands also if you happen to
have covid
and you are breathing into the particles
of these masks it's like dandelion root
that you can breathe and aspirate these
particles and it can actually make it
more harmful
not to mention the fact that it makes
you look like a dick yeah
that's the most important one i don't
listen i don't i don't like to make
absolute litmus tests
if you wear two masks we will never be
friends never
you are not welcome to my house ever and
i have house parties with more than six
people all the time sending a guest
i don't care yeah it's true you do i
love all the people saying you know to
taking pictures and selfies and stuff
and putting it online with two masks
it's like oh my gosh
the double mask took a picture of men
you know themselves crying
selfies and put it on instagram like
that was okay
it's like you're crying because biden
one you're not my
friend put a mask over your whole
[ __ ]
plastic with packing peanuts sad and a
rubber band
and not to mention there's a problem the
the double mask
is the mark of the anti-science beast
okay
the double mask is the mark of the
anti-science beast because you don't
believe in science you have no respect
for the scientific process
not to mention the worse the worst
effects which is
the societal ramifications of everyone
being
degraded everyone being insulted and
cable to science denier
if they did not in fact wear two masks
um but here you go
this is something just in case you think
it was just dr fauci this was parroted
and you were actually given instructions
on mainstream media predicated on the
idea of a scientific basis
as to how to utilize the double mask
certainly if you have an
immunocompromised condition or any other
medical problem that you did
that is uh seriously compromise your
immune system or you're older
then you might be a person who needs to
wear two masks especially in more
dangerous situations
like going out in crowded spaces select
joe biden does it
mitt romney double masked during the
capital insurrection
tom cruise also double masks actually
putting the cloth mask
first and then putting the surgical mask
on top of it just made this an n95 right
here wearing
two good quality masks can provide
an extra layer of protection yeah you
got to think it's just
an added layer added wall between you
and the world there with regards to
doubling up on surgical
or cloth masks i would say that that
adds extra protection in terms of the
droplets being expelled
place the surgical mask on your face
first now place the cloth mask on top
the cloth mask provides a physical
barrier to respiratory droplets
well there you go when it turns out
there's no science behind any of that
don't you love that instruction there
they're going to
and by the did you notice that the last
one that was washington post yeah was
telling you to do it the opposite way
yeah tom cruise was just trying to
replace his two beards
[Laughter]
by the way the masks don't work at all
if you have facial hair did you know
that that's true that's what they said
like it doesn't work shave your facial
hair
so just shave our facial hair way too
okay what's the instructions
shave your facial hair okay don't wear a
mask actually you should wear a mask
now wear two masks no put it back put it
back put it back one mask like
then and then at any point if you go
hold on a second is there science for
any of this [ __ ]
you're labeled a science denier right i
don't think i've ever seen someone deny
science
more than fouchy if his previous
statement was considered science which
every statement he makes is considered
science by the left right now everything
he says is gospel
do we still are we able to get thomas
finnegan we are going to be able to get
thomas
okay because this is a thing we're going
to be talking tomorrow about the science
from tests and listen i want people to
get tested yeah by the way anyone in the
studio here who wants a vaccine i'm just
going to hit this talk to the controller
anyone in the control room out there who
wants a vaccine i'll pay uh for anyone
who wants vaccine i don't want one okay
um and uh i i want people here to
understand this
and i want people to stay safe yes of
course but the tests have not been what
we were told the vaccines which they
said you shouldn't trust now they're
saying the trust they're
masking now without you saying there is
no science for it the good news is
though um at least the
the good old the chinese are coming up
with some new methods and right now this
is uh
on i mean it's it's making its way to
the public the um
they feel pretty good about the new
testing a new anal swab i think it's
coming out
[Music]
oh let's make sure we got this that yeah
this is oh that was
so this is actually what they're
developing in china right now
to check your viral load must be their
anniversary
[Laughter]
so um and yeah that's enough and i think
you know here sometimes that ladder with
credit we get an exclusive before other
people
do um we get access you know listen we
get access to spartan armor walther
um we have um i guess what would you
call it sort of premier access
to the anal swab um and thomas finnegan
is actually testing it for you time to
go on the ground with thomas finnegan
[Music]
all right thomas finnegan are you there
sir can you hear us
yes stephen good morning how are you
good morning okay let us know fill us in
what's going on
what is this new covid testing method
what can people expect
well it depends uh on how you look at it
the way i like to look at it is
we're looking for accuracy okay and you
go straight to the horse's mouth
uh to get that okay and when can we
expect the rollout
well that again it depends on you know
your location and uh
which which which um uh municipality
you're right
they all have their own schedules it's
very district to district
exactly and uh
you get swab now okay uh now we have our
next guess hopefully thomas finnegan
figures
i hope he finds what he's looking for
really great he has no price it really
hasn't
you can't put a price on accuracy and
watch in two months we'll find out that
does
nothing for you of course like christmas
some gay chinese doctor like oh in a
swamp yeah
this is a good show this is a good show
and our next guest is a good guest
it is time for the guest segment with
mike rowe everybody
senior row i am sorry for that
introduction how are you sir
i'm living the dream dude or whatever
this is yeah well you know
you can call it whatever you want some
people say nightmare uh your twitter
is microworks that still does work
ironically and um i wanted to talk with
you about about a few things you have
this new show right six degrees with
mike rowe
and um can you explain for people who
don't know and we'll get to what's
happened with the show
what the show is what what it was about
sure but i feel duty bound to first show
you that the masks microworks has
embraced
uh say safety third
and we've sold a ton of them and um
i just couldn't help but watch and think
to myself you know anybody who's going
to put two of those things on or maybe
why stop it too right right i mean
c4 or whatever well
i want those for my mom because my mom
is french canadian and i just want to
hear her talk about her safety turd
mask right because she can't say what
t's or h's she can't say t's or h's and
she adds s's where there are none and
she never used plurals where they should
be
so when we are we're having twins we're
going to name our daughter edder so
just for just just to bust our shots
that's awesome so safety third okay
yeah yeah oh uh six degrees brand new
show disc
discovery plus new streaming service
it's a um
it's a history show for people who
wouldn't watch history shows
each episode starts with a a truly
stupid question
um can a horseshoe help you find your
soulmate can a
mousetrap cure your hangover can a sheep
do your taxes the answer to these
questions is always yes
wow but i get an hour to try and connect
these two seemingly disparate points by
walking through time and space
on a budget and bringing various events
to life
vis-a-vis a surprising use of animation
puppets
archival footage suspicious reenactments
costumes that rarely fit yeah wigs that
don't cover people's heads entirely
it's kind of a hot mess so it's kind of
a rube goldberg
for the social media attention span it
is i mean
there was a show on years ago in the 70s
called connections
which was hosted by a brilliant guy
named james byrne
who's the college professor we all wish
we had and he
he did this show he would walk through
like the moors of
england you know in his white leisure
suit with his
hair snapping in the breeze explaining
why it is that the tracks left by the
first
roman chariots are of the same dimension
as the tracks left on the moon
by the lunar lander well not to be
confused with the moors who you know
changed the tint over there in sicily
that's another story beethoven you
should talk about beethoven one day in
his ancestry
christopher walken true romance true
romance
uh i don't know if we can get banned for
even referencing a classic film now
but um that is fascinating and this is
uh this is on discovery and it's like
you say
it's designed for people maybe who don't
necessarily watch history shows but i
gotta tell you
most history shows suck and this is why
um i was on my honeymoon
and it was the history channel at this
point and it was raining and there's
only you know
at a certain point you can't spare the
fluids and so we were in our room
and uh it was a history channel or
discovery channel and it was remember
the mermaid special
the special on the mermaid and i didn't
have cable for years
and so i tuned into the history channel
and i thought it was what the history
channel
had been when i had seen it years ago so
this is this is about mermaids
so it sounds to me like what you're
doing is actually far more valuable than
what most of these uh
educational channels and they're always
a lot of midgets who are like buying
dresses
it doesn't seem like they're educational
morbidly obese people yeah
well you've also got to look out for the
morbidly obese midgets
yes you don't see a lot of but they're
out there and it's very difficult to
know
they can't swim well no
watching them but they're buoyant
they're buoyant so it makes up for it
i'm watching them shopping
sorry there was a time when
you know the history channel wasn't just
an h it was really the whole thing was
history and discovery wasn't just a d
and non-fiction really meant the absence
of fiction
and reality actually meant the presence
of
real things right and um in those days
there was a show called dirty jobs which
i was happy to do that
that used something we called a truth
cam which was really just a documentary
camera we never stopped rolling on that
show because we never did a second take
right and so i would use the footage
from that camera to try and prove to the
viewer that we weren't completely full
of crap
right and you know telling them a
made-up story
on six degrees we do the same thing
except dirty jobs
was really the making of a show about
dirty jobs and this is the making of a
show
about a bunch of people who had some
bourbon and tried to figure out a neat
parlor trick based on six degrees of
kevin bacon but couldn't find kevin
bacon so got mike rowe
to do this thing instead yeah well you
know what listen if you can't get a tom
cruise you get a jude loft you can't get
a kevin bacon you get a micro but i
would choose mike rowe one of the
greatest compliments i ever got was you
know when i could start growing a beard
facial scruff
at the age of 22. um i had a lady who
said
i really like that it's like that sexy
oh mike rowe from dirty jobs i love she
just she wouldn't stop talking
about your script yeah i had a lady tell
me i had the sexy scruff of mike rowe
um and then she told me that it looked
like i had tits because i was fat at
that point
there's pain stephen yes there is that's
a backhanded compliment if i've ever
heard it
it was mainly just an insult but i want
to move to this and then we're going to
go um
uh to mug club exclusive because
sometimes we can't talk about everything
on the youtube
he had a show a facebook show as well
and this is called returning the favor
and it was extremely popular
well received now it was cancelled from
what i understand i don't want to speak
out of turn
why was the show canceled was it
cancelled what's the story behind that
because
as you know uh a lot of things are being
removed from the history books or social
media platforms these days
yeah so on my page right now
there are about 30 000 people who are
who are fairly upset and on the
returning the favor page there are two
and a half million people
who just learned that one of the most
popular shows on facebook
uh was canceled last week at at the
height
seemingly at the height of its
popularity an emmy award-winning show
stephen i don't know if you
noticed but can you see the emmy okay
back there i can't but i was looking at
your scruff
it's the depth of field effect i just i
just can't stop looking at your pudding
but uh i'm sure it's lovely
yes it's it's awesome anyway um
the show was canceled after four seasons
and a hundred episodes and a lot of
people
are assuming that it's because i may
have said or
done something to run afoul of the
powers that be
and so i've been making the rounds
telling
my story of this thing which is really
not a terribly exciting story it's
it's that the show got cancelled i don't
think i did
but the show definitely did but why did
it get canceled if it was its height and
so popular
now this is where it gets a little weird
okay i appreciate you being diplomatic
and i feel ignorant here this is like
one of the worst interviews that was
ever conducted was larry king versus
jerry's uh with jerry seinfeld i don't
know if you ever saw that where he goes
he goes jerry he goes seinfeld to be
clear
wasn't cancelled larry wasn't cancer
you walked away number one show of all
day can someone get larry my resume
laurie it was almost as good as when he
asked the snowboarder how important is
the board
right up there with the snow yeah kind
of need two things
three if you count the weed so why again
because the arc if it's so pi and i know
that it was so popular and i'm not even
on facebook where
i had to go to facebook to watch some of
these installments
did you get an answer as to why it was
canceled because you didn't cancel it
you didn't choose to walk
away here's what's important to me the
show's got
a lot of fans and they're all asking me
if i can take it someplace else
a no i didn't own that particular show
b i don't want people to think i pulled
the plug
i didn't and c and maybe most
importantly
modesty aside is i don't want people
think the show didn't work
because it wasn't successful all those
things were true right
but in this stupid business that we're
in
big companies make big decisions for all
sorts of incomprehensible reasons dirty
jobs was canceled at the height of its
popularity and i moped around for a
couple of months
not understanding how the network could
make a call like that
and this is hard for me to say i know
what's going on with you on facebook
and on a personal level i've been very
vocal
about the things that that worry me i
i'm worried about censorship i'm worried
about safe spaces i don't think any of
that's good for the country
and here i am with a hit show that just
went away
and the truth of it is as best as i can
tell
i well i didn't get canceled i got fired
well you
fired four but you didn't get fired
because they could swap you out and by
the way if you are looking to bring the
show somewhere we could bring it under
the mug club banner and we could just
you know retitle it performing facebook
but i think that um you weren't fired
because they would have swapped you out
with another host right they would have
been like and uh
performing favors with dave rubin or you
know whoever you know tim poole
um the show was cam do you think it had
anything to do with effect for people
who don't know
this show also was sort of highlighting
the fact that we
as a society place so much value on
overpriced college degrees you've been
championing this cause for a long time
not because you hate the institution of
education but because you
when i hear you talk about i can tell it
you passionately you compassionately
want people to be gainfully employed
and to be able to live out the american
dream and that
in many instances for many people the
path is trade schools
running small businesses i mean it goes
back to dirty jobs but that was a big
part
of your show returning the favor correct
facebook has allowed me to
build a foundation from really the
ground up i mean i started that
microworks uh 13 years ago on labor day
but in 2012 we started raising money and
awarding work ethic
scholarships about five five and a half
million dollars so far
and um i couldn't have done it without
facebook right
and and this is just a reality of the
world we live in course you
you wind up sooner or later kind of
resenting the thing you
rely upon whether it's affordable
electricity
or you know go go down the list well
social media is no different
so i'm suddenly in this position now
where i've got six million people on a
facebook page
i've been able to use it uh to do i
think a pretty good thing as well as
this show by the way returning the favor
which was just a straight-up
unapologetic anthem
to do gooderry i mean we just
highlighted people
in zip codes you've never been to doing
nice things
for their community it it was a show
taylor made for these times
right but to your point something weird
has happened with our language
today and when you talk about things
like
work ethic delayed gratification
personal responsibility attitude
right all of those things go into our
work ethic scholarship program and you
have to sign a document a sweat pledge
that basically says
i'm on board with all this stuff right
that position
i don't know when it happened but
sometime between 2010 and today
those words all became problematic
yeah and for some reason more associated
with one side of the aisle
than the other so a lot of people on my
page
right now as we're talking are like oh
no your show got cancelled because you
talked about work ethic
for the record i don't think that's what
happened but i understand why people
would look at it and say
what other explanation can there be and
that's why i'm in such a profoundly
weird spot have you asked for answers as
to why it got canceled or is that
something you can't talk about because
it seems like they could just say oh uh
you know
you cost too much uh everybody doing
your uh you know you did your four
commercials and everyone will you know
we don't we're facebook we don't have
any money we're broke yeah
look nothing to an outside objector
really lines up
right if you're facebook you can't say
we ran out of money on the other hand
you know how it works budgets are
budgets covid came
their next season of shows wound up
getting paid for with money that might
have been allocated for this and
everything got put on hold and so forth
and so on
bottom line was they were very gracious
they called me they said look this sucks
but this is what we got to do we had a
great run we did 100 episodes
hope there are no hard feelings and i
said you know what there are no hard
feelings
i appreciate the fact that you guys
support my foundation
and so forth so right i would say hard
feelings i'd say very hard feelings
but dude this is the thing this is this
is
i think part i'm petty and small-minded
so
take that into account i am two i am too
but we can either two things can be true
at the same time yeah
they have to be and it's true
that i share your concern for
all things libertarian and all things
first amendment i really do
it's also true that i've built a
foundation and a business
yeah around six million people on a
facebook page that coincidentally green
lit a show
four years ago that a bunch of people
also like of course now
i can i can lean into one and i'll sound
like a sycophant
for big tech or i can lean into the
other and i'll sound like an anarchist
in my bunker you know wearing a wearing
a bulletproof vest or whatever's going
on a sponsor
that's a sponsor i get it but it's like
where the hell do you draw a line and
like i think the country is trapped
right we're just trapped in one or the
other well you know what i've got
paul at the uh the prison of two ideas i
don't know i don't have cable but
i do want to uh speaking with so before
we go because i want to talk a little
bit more here for mug club members so
you can say whatever you want he's just
a
foul-mouthed little man when he gets uh
off the youtube
uh where can people watch the six to six
degrees with mike rowe
discovery [ __ ] plus plus
discovery plus uh it is micro and by the
way everyone we are about to leave we're
gonna be taking your chat playing bad
movie lines continuing with mike
rowe actually might not play bad movie
lens we might save that for tomorrow
because i'm enjoying my time with mike
rowe
uh and if you're on youtube right now
look comment comment comment once this
is archives just leave a comment that
helps us through the algorithms
today just name your favorite dog breed
and tell me if you think the impeachment
is constitutional youtube we love you
but not really you see what we're doing
with facebook piss